Get cleo. Thank you Keith. Justin,
everybody has been instrumental in getting
the out here up from sunny southern
California in San Diego.
That's a true pleasure to be here.
And I'm interested in sharing some ideas
with you that I've had for a couple of
years now, but really came into
sharp focus just just about, uh,
three or four years ago when we made a
discovery that made front page headlines
around the world and it was done in such
a way as to captivate the attention of
people, young and old, uh, you
know, of all, all different,
all different nationalities because what
it spoke to was how did the universe
come to be the way that we see it today?
And I'm going to talk to you about that
and the concomitant intertwining with
this most prestigious of all accolades
on earth, namely the Nobel prize.
And I came to encounter it and
obviously, you know, spoiler alert,
I did not win the Nobel prize. This
is not real, this one over here. Uh,
but it's edible or not.
Sometimes you know, sometimes
that's even more preferable.
You want to talk to you about how we came
to make this discovery and sort of the
summary of the book can be shown
and, and just one, one picture,
as most things can be described,
there's a picture made in nature
magazine and on the occasion of my a book
release and it shows a telescope are
our neighbor telescope at the South Pole
staring up to the heavens and fixated
and focused in some sense on the Nobel
prize. That's a picture of our, uh,
the famous Nobel prize rendered as if
it is the s this type of heat that I
studied that I will talk to you about
today called the cosmic microwave
background radiation,
the oldest light in the universe.
But before we get into the pursuit of
the Nobel Prize and the ultimate, uh, uh,
the loss of,
of winning Alfred's namesake medallion,
I want to explore a little bit of how
the Nobel Prize came to be so venerated,
so esteemed that it really dominates
headlines around the world.
And I can't really,
you know,
thank the media enough because right now
the Nobel prize and our fearless leader,
Donald Trump, our air are in the news
almost on an hourly basis. So we'll,
we'll get to that towards the very end
when I talk about some ideas that I'm
proposing my book and arguments I
make for a modification to a society's
superlative prize. So how did the
Nobel prize get to be so esteem? Well,
first, a brief history of the Nobel prize.
So the history is that Alfred Nobel,
his family and his father
were great inventors and
they were inventors of deadly
technologies in particular. They invented
landmines and see mines, uh, during the,
uh, one of the Russian wars
in the mid 18 hundreds. Uh,
at some point czar Nicholas decided
that they were done with war in Russia.
And you know, that came to be true,
right? There are no more wars.
The Russia after the 1860s. Right? So,
but they cut all the ties to the
Nobel F and F and son's business,
which we're making these deadly munitions.
And that kind of drove the older,
the father,
elder Nobel Emmanuel Nobel crazy.
And he ended up seating control of his
business. His to his oldest son, Ludvig.
In between there was a huge boom,
a building boom in the west in
particular in the United States.
We were building railways, expanding them
from the east coast to the west coast.
And at that time they needed to do,
they needed some way of mass excavation
and they were using Nitroglycerin,
which is incredibly unstable.
And in fact,
if you take nitroglycerin and you drop it,
it will explode.
And actually happened to
Alfred's baby brother a meal.
So Alford's a baby brother Emil was
trying to synthesize a stable version of
nitroglycerin. He failed
miserably. Unfortunately,
he died as well as three of
his lab mates. So, you know,
I use that as a cautionary
tale in my lab all the time.
And just three years later,
Alfred invented dynamite.
And I'll talk about
that in the next slide.
But dynamite was a real revolution
because it was stabilized.
It was actually made of completely
edible ingredients. Nitroglycerin,
which Alfred himself would
take for angina. And, uh, and,
and things like chalk and anti
acids and things like that.
But when combined in just
the right proportion,
as many inventions of that you guys are
familiar with, then you get the secret.
You get the secret sauce that really
made Alfred one of the richest people in
the world.
Then an 1888 Alfred was walking around
in Paris where he would soon be exiled
for, for a siding with the
enemy of France, namely Italy,
and building them war munitions.
And he was walking down the street.
So I headline and the headline said, the
merchant of death, Alfred Nobel is dead.
And there was like a celebratory obituary,
if you can imagine that.
Very obstreperous. So he, he saw this
headline and he realized, hmm, you know,
I'm very much alive.
You know,
the reports of my demise are
a little bit exaggerated,
but it was actually his older brother
Ludvig the one who had received control,
the business of Nobel
and sons from his father.
So Alfred read that and actually it,
he treated it as a great gift because
he realized that if he didn't change his
ways, that the way the newspaper
described him as the merchant of death,
the person responsible for more deaths
in human history than any other person,
that would be the legacy that
he would be remembered by.
So he resolved then to change
this. And he really, and my sense,
he endowed the Nobel prize a
few years later in an attempt,
I think at public relations
and it was wildly successful.
So if you go to Google, patents are
patents.google. You'll find, uh,
an invention list of 355 inventions.
The most profitable was dynamite.
Dynamite outfit. Nobel. Actually,
he did some ab testing on Google
adwords back then and he was going to
originally call it Nobel's safety powder.
You know,
it was like a euphemism
because he wanted to,
people knew that Nitroglycerin
was very, uh, you know,
have this connotation of being deadly.
In fact,
when people at the drug store would
have to buy nitroglycerin 18 hundreds,
they wouldn't ask for it.
They call it,
they made up a name for our called
trying to train or something like that.
And that was done to not scare
the chemist or the pharmacist.
So he made this a substance later the,
the a choice and the Ab testing
dynamite one and it means power rock.
And there's some pictures of
what it looked like. And uh,
this made him one of the wealthiest
people in the world at that time.
With that money, he endowed this
Medallian, this prize that bears his name.
He indict endowed five prizes
and peace, chemistry, literature,
medicine or physiology,
and my field of physics.
And what was so interesting to me is to,
as I'll show you later on
in the pro in this talk,
not only did I personally
lose the Nobel prize,
but I was asked to nominate the winners
of the Nobel prize the very next year
after I lost it. Okay. It's kind
of bittersweet and uh, and it,
and it actually led me to this voyage of
exploration and hopefully a reformation
for humanities superlative prize.
So this prize was endowed
by Alfred Nobel's will, and
he wrote it down by hand.
And the prize was, uh, was, was,
it was, it was so important to him.
He specified exactly what he wanted
to happen and what would be, uh, the,
the ultimate aim of this prize. And
I'll explain what he wanted as we go on.
But the first thing I want to say is
that, um, this story involves, uh, if you,
if you will, the villain
in my book is, uh,
is this very humble substance called dust.
And I have,
I'm blessed to have five children
now. I'm very familiar with dust, uh,
but it's a different kind of dust.
But, but it made me think back when,
when you'll see the encounter that I'll
describe scientifically in this book
between dust and me and my experiment,
it made me think of the biblical verse
that goes ashes to ashes, dust to dust.
So it means that humanity,
humans start off their life,
basically is nothing but dust.
And then we end,
our ultimate aim of everybody is
dust. And so poetically. I thought,
well that's kind of interesting because
the history of astronomy also begins in
some sense with dust and
start us, literally flows
through our veins right now.
The iron in the hemoglobin in your blood
was once and the core of a supernova
that exploded and
repopulated the universe,
the cosmos in our local solar neighborhood
with heavy elements and those heavy
elements eventually coalesced and
made their way into your bloodstream.
So dust is a villain in some sense
in this book as you'll find out.
But we're not the only ones who have been
bedeviled by dust devils in the cosmos.
The first one was the first astronomer
and history to use a telescope.
Galileo Galilei, there's a sketch
of his telescope and he, of course,
there's a sketch of his telescope.
He used his telescope to make discoveries
that were impossible to make with the
human eye unaided. And this telescope,
this tiny little thing that you can get a,
I'm not at a bookstore
sometimes on a bookstore,
I'm forbidden to use a certain online
retailer that starts with a and a so.
So I said, nowadays you
can buy a telescope online
on Google shopping.google.
Right? And it costs less than some
apps that you guys probably make.
Okay. So this is something that
if you have a child in your life,
even here in Los Angeles or
the bay area or wherever,
you can see the same exact sites that
Galileo saw. And what did he see?
Some of it is depicted here. Those
are his sketches. Some of the first,
what I call stop motion animation of
what the moons of Jupiter were doing.
So these are the orbits is a Pr,
a plot that he made in the early part
of 1610 of what the planet Jupiter look
like through his telescope.
Tiny little thing.
And he saw that there were these stars
and he called these stars the muddied she
satellites. So he named the the,
the satellites after his patrons,
after his benefactors, the Medici
family of, of northern Italy.
And you see also he made depictions of
the planet Venus and saw that it had this
strange behavior where it would
change its phase, its shape,
it would look like a miniature
moon with Crescent, and then, uh,
give us phase and the moon.
And Saturn appeared as if he had
these weird pitcher like ears on it.
And then you see the sketches of the moon
on the, uh, on the upper right as well.
So what Galileo did was so titanic,
because he overthrew the paradigm and
that the Earth was the sole center of the
universe.
So back then they considered the solar
system to be the entire universe.
And the Earth was the
center of the solar system.
So therefore the earth was the center
of this or the, of the entire universe.
What they didn't know until Galileo used
the telescope was that there were other
centers of the solar system.
So it could not be unique that the
earth is the center of the solar system.
If there's another center, namely the
planet Jupiter. So Galileo didn't as,
as people often misconstrue
what Galileo did,
he didn't prove the Copernican hypothesis.
He didn't prove that the sun is the
center of the, uh, of the, uh, universe.
He's just disproved that the earth
is the only center of the universe.
Because I was an important, you know, if
overly belabored I'm an academician. Okay,
so forgive me, but I claim, you
know, as brilliant as he was,
he made some blunders and he made many
blunders and they were done in a service
to further confirm the Copernican
hypothesis. He went to his grave as you,
as you may know, uh, for basically
committing the crime of heresy,
suggesting that the earth was
not the center of the universe.
And in part of that,
he never really recanted this decision
that he believes so strongly in that he
was, uh, basically unwilling to
part with. But not only that,
he used every piece of evidence that he
had in physics and in astronomy to try
to bolster his argument. And it's a
phenomenon known as confirmation bias.
And we as human beings and scientists,
as you guys know,
are also human beings despite
the stereotypes to the contrary.
But this little asterisk them.
Does anyone know what this aster ism is?
Maybe some of you drive one of these
asterisk gums. This is Subaru in Japanese.
It means the seven sisters a plea,
80s,
the eighties in Greek literature
where the nurses of Dionysus,
who was the god of the grape. So he's
responsible for all our wine. Uh,
and they were his nurses.
I Dunno how they got that.
These little stars are like that.
In fact,
you can only see six of them
with the even good eyes. Uh,
but Galileo went even further with this.
He looked at the constellation,
there's a little asterisk and he
sketched it as it appeared to his eye.
And Edward Tufte, the famous, uh, uh,
kind of sociologist of science
or re recontour of science.
He calls Galileo the world's
first data scientist.
So I'm sure there's a lot of data
scientists here. So if you see here,
Dalai was depicting the Pleiades,
the seven sisters and an
interesting unique fashion.
He showing two different types of stars.
There are open stars like stars
of David was six points on them.
And then there's filled in,
completely closed in stars
and they're totally different.
And I want you to for a second
what those could possibly mean.
I actually gave this talk to a bunch of
astronomers at Caltech a couple of days
ago and they couldn't understand that.
Almost none of them guess what it meant.
But I'll, I'll give you a second
to think about it. And then, uh,
we can also read what Galileo
rope beneath it. He said,
what we observed is the nature of
the matter of Milky Way itself,
which with the aid of the spyglass,
which is what he called the telescope,
is observed so well that it,
that all the disciplines that for so
many generations have vexed philosophers
can be destroyed by visible certainty
and we are liberated from their wordy
arguments. Okay. So back then, physicists
weren't great fans of philosophers,
even nowadays that's, that's also held
to be true. But if you're, if you're,
if you haven't come up with the answer
to what do these different types of
iconography, what did they
represent? The stars that are open,
these six pointed stars of Dave,
those represents stars that the human
eye can see on aided the stars that are
black and filled in or those that
he can only see with a telescope.
And he said that the entire constantly,
or the tire aster ism,
it's technically not
called the constellation,
but it's a little collection of stars
that the entire star collection,
which is shown here through the
Hubble telescope, that this can be,
could be resolved into stars,
even the glowing gaseous nebulosity,
what we call nebulosity now,
when in fact now we know that even
with a much more powerful telescope,
even the Hubble telescope 50 times
bigger in diameter, uh, then,
then Galileo's that you still can't
resolve the nebulosity and to stars.
And so what was it he was trying to say
that the nature of the Milky Way was
purely made of stars.
So first he demoted the,
the earth from the center
of the solar system.
Then he said the son could be the center
of the solar system. And then he said,
the sun is just like any other star in
the Milky Way. So it's quite interesting.
Everything that he's using is done in a
furtherance of the Copernican hypothesis.
So it's a confirmation bias example,
par exsalonce.
He later went on to conjecture that the
tides that we feel here on earth are
caused by the rotation of the earth on
its axis and also the revolution of the
earth around the sun. We now know
that to be completely incorrect,
the tides that we feel, high tide,
low tide here near the beach,
are caused by the Moon's gravitational
influence. But why did he want to,
why do you want to say it was from
the Earth's motion around the sun?
Because that meant that the earth went
around the sun and it's completely wrong.
So even the greatest intellectual
physicist in history, Galileo, uh,
to some of us made blunders and they were
done because of what he wanted to see.
And that's a theme that runs
throughout cosmology to this very day.
And sad to report affected us on my
project called Bicep that I'll talk about.
So Galileo made this blender, okay?
It's not the worst blender you can make,
you know, with the first telescope in
human history. Uh, but you see here,
one other thing to notice is
that this is a nebulosity.
This nebulosity is not stars. It's
actually made of gas. It's made of dust,
and it's made a particles
that act like little mirrors.
And some of them are my metallic as well.
So we actually know that they twinkle
in a sense because of the reflection of
the star light off of
tiny mirrors of dust.
So Galileo was deceived by dust into
thinking that the sun was just a star,
like any other star.
And the vast assemblage of stars
we call the Milky Way Galaxy.
So not all that twinkle's is a diamond.
So that'll be a theme throughout.
So again, the Copernican
model, which wasn't proven.
So by the standards of
mathematical proof in science,
what we do is really disprove
other hypotheses. So what
Galileo technically did,
his disprove the Ptolemaic Aristotelian
ancient Greek conception of the central
central position of the
Earth about the cosmos.
And you see the more complicated version
of Copernicus and Galileo on the right.
So what we're trying to do now,
and what I describe in my book
is since the time of Galileo,
there've been four other
Copernican revolutions,
there've been revolutions after Galileo
disabused humanity of its central
purpose in central point in
the universe's arrangement.
The next group of astronomers
promptly forgot that lesson.
Then the best astronomer,
one of the best astronomers,
the 17 hundreds named William Herschel.
He made a map of the Milky Way Galaxy,
and guess where he put the earth and
the sun at the center of the Milky Way
Galaxy, where it's actually technically
not located there. The next, uh,
couple of what are called
great debates in my book,
they were corresponding to is the Milky
Way Galaxy, the center of the universe,
and was our galaxy central not
only in space, but in time.
Is there something special
about humanities, galaxy, et
Cetera, in time and space.
And then the question is,
is our universe the only universe or is
what's called the multiverse centered on
us as well? That's the last of
the five debates in my book.
But I say there's many more of
these debates to come where humanity
overemphasizes it's importance and
nature conspires like the ultimate big
brother to say you're not that
great. And that's what happens. Okay.
I've got a big brother and I've got three
sons and I'm also a big brother so I
can say that.
So I want to show you guys something kind
of cool cause this took place just up
the road from you guys and it has a night.
A nice, really cool Google connection.
So in the 1960s this was
the original Internet. Okay.
So they launched a balloon.
Some are over central Kansas and from JPL,
just up the road in Pasadena,
they shot radio waves that bounced off
this giant metallic reflective mylar co
covered balloon. And they
bounced. Those signals are,
they tried to bounce those signals to a
receiving horn in Homedale New Jersey.
So it was trans continental
communication with radio waves.
And so what this reminds me of nowadays
is what you guys do here or do elsewhere
within the, within the
corporation is get Internet. Okay?
Except this Internet says your motto is
balloon powered Internet for everyone.
So that was balloon powered Internet
for one communicator at a time.
So if they were, you know, if, if,
if someone was on the phone
or using the Internet,
it was much worse than dial up even.
But they found they couldn't get it to
work because the balloon signal decreases.
Uh, sort of like the fourth power of the
distance they were trying to transmit.
So instead they launched a tiny little
satellite into space and it was called
Telstar.
Now you guys,
by the looks of it are way too young to
remember when the first communication
satellites were launched.
But actually Sputnik,
the very first satellite ever launched
and the night late 1950s was basically a
radio transmitter.
And that solved a lot of the
problems of the inverse square law,
which kills the power,
transmitted and kills the power received.
And so they launched a satellite
into space and these astronomers,
Penzias and Wilson using that same
horn and 10 I used with the reflective
balloon,
they were using this to see if they
could see the signal to noise that they
needed to do real internet
communications using a transceiver,
a device that could receive a signals
from California and the amplify them,
boost them and send them down.
This work fantastically well,
except when they kept looking at the
satellite through their telescope,
they didn't get the signal to noise.
They predicted and they were very diligent
scientists and they tracked down all
the sources of error they could find,
including the fact that there was a,
there was a nest of pigeons inside of
this antenna that would not go away.
In fact,
Penzias over here.
He took them in his car and drove him
from northern New Jersey to Philadelphia,
and guess what? These are homing
pigeons. So what do they do?
They came back and they described it,
these pigeons as leaving a
white dielectric material
inside the heart that they
couldn't get her.
They scrubbed that they cleaned it.
Finally they couldn't get rid of
it. So they went to to um, you know,
their quarter master or whatever and they
said, we need a shotgun. And they said,
why? They said, we've got to
kill these birds. And they did.
And Penzias later recounted,
he said the birds left with a little
bang and then we discovered the big bang.
And that's really what happened next.
So they ended up making a map of the sky
that they could not remove a persistent
three degree Kelvin above absolute
zero glow coming in all directions,
which if you had microwave vision to
your eyes without the aid of boosting
contrast,
this is what you'd see.
If you could see microwave's
you'd go out and look around.
Everything surrounding the earth would
be colored in a certain sense. Constant,
persistent, never changing with
season or direction or anything.
It's a background that comes from the
big bang because they were looking back
not only in space,
but they were looking back in time.
Nowadays we can subtract
the average signal.
This three Kelvin signal and
some of my colleagues at, uh,
NASA made an a beautiful animation of
what this picture would look like if you
add very high contrast.
In addition to high sensitivity,
you would see tiny ripples,
tiny fluctuations in this pattern.
So if you zoom in on this image
after boosting up it's contrast,
you see that it has
fluctuations in temperature,
the temperature is not exactly three
Kelvin and some places it's three Kelvin
plus 10 Microkelvin, 10 millions of a
Calvin and some other places. It's 10,
three Kelvin minus 10.
Microkelvin.
That's about the size of how much it
varies from point to point on the sky.
And thank goodness it does vary
because without those variations,
the matter that makes up the stars and
galaxies in our universe wouldn't know
where to coagulate in a uniform universe.
And it was known that this was true from
the time of Laplas and Newton, that the,
uh,
uniformly distributed universal uniform
matter throughout would never provide a
nucleation site for matter to a
agglomerate to create the stars,
planets and galaxies that we see today.
So that's a nice image there.
The question is what caused those
fluctuations? In the beginning,
you could imagine that you could explain
something if it was perfectly smooth
and you can explain something
that is widely, not smooth,
but it's very hard to get fine
tuned amounts of fluctuation.
So 10 microkelvin out of say,
let's just call it 10 Kelvin,
that's a few parts per million.
It's fine tuning.
Where does that smoothness come from?
That's smooth but not perfectly smooth.
It's actually smoother than
the surface of a bowling ball.
Any bowling ball smoother than my bowling
ball because I'm a terrible bowler and
I make big dents in it, but the surface
of a bowling ball compared to its,
its radius instantaneously compared to
its average radius varies by about 10
times that amount. The Universe is much
smoother than anything than any other,
you know, naturally occurring thing
that you might be familiar with.
So we set out to try to understand
where do those fluctuations come from.
And we built a telescope
called Bicep to do it.
The theory underpinning why there
should be fluctuations. The,
the leading candidate
theory is called inflation.
Inflation predicts that in
the extremely early universe,
a trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth after the big bang that the
universe underwent this strange kind
of phase transition that was quantum in
nature.
And the amount of expansion varied from
point to point in space because quantum
fields do that.
There are rare random variables and
they'll have fluctuations in them that
technically are called
Gaussian random fluctuations.
And that could lead to enough fine tuning
that you could get a universe that's
smooth but not perfectly
smooth. And again, without the,
without the deviation from perfect
smoothness, we would not be here.
There'd be no way for galaxy to know
where to form if you like. So we were,
we were interested in trying to measure
this extremely early fraction of a,
of a trillionth of a trillionth
of a second after the big bang.
This is called inflation.
It's very hard to depict something that
nobody knows anything really about.
And so, you know, sometimes it's
just shown as a giant question mark.
I don't think that's too useful.
This is meant to illustrate that the
universe had these quantum fluctuations
throughout it and they would lead to
variations which would later cause these
temperature patterns to originate.
And that's exactly the leading candidate
of the early cosmo genic theory of,
of the universe. So I like to compare
this to another form of evolution.
So if there are some, you know, biology,
uh, uh, Aficionados in the audience,
you may recognize this object.
This is called a blastocyst.
It's a collection of human cells about a
thousand seconds after your parents had
their own personal big bang.
This object has about a hundred or so
cells and it will later evolve into
somebody.
But we're,
we're trying to do is take an image of
somebody today or the universe as it
looks to us today and then extrapolate
back in time to what the universe was
like 50 orders of
magnitude earlier in time.
Here's what you look like
at a thousand seconds.
And imagine trying to understand what the,
what this blastocyst is embryo become.
What would it look like? Who has a guest?
Anyone have a guess at Eric Schmidt? No,
nobody liked that. Okay. So I'll give
you a hint. I'm going to you a hint here.
I'll go put some identifying
features on the blastocyst.
And then of course we recognize it as
my children's favorite astrophysicist.
You don't know how bad that feels.
Okay? And I'm care about Daddy.
They care about Neil.
Uh,
so here's how he looks at an age of
about being generous. 2 billion seconds.
You want to feel old, quote your agent
seconds. That's about 50, 59 years,
I think he is.
Um,
and if you want to extrapolate back
to what he was as a blastocyst,
that's a factor of 2 million.
We're trying to go 50 orders of magnitude,
not six orders of magnitude,
50 orders of magnitude.
We thought we could do it using a very
special type of telescope because the
Telus, if the telescope,
we're sensitive, what,
what's called the lights polarization,
then the reverberations of
spacetime produced during inflation.
What produced this crazy twisting curl
mode pattern on the microwave sky.
So in addition to the
temperature fluctuations,
there'd be variations in polarization.
So we have Polaroids.
You guys living in southern California
to have to have these, they're de Rigor.
These are my state university funded
a solid sunglasses that I get to wear.
These are sensitive to one
orientation of the lights,
polarization and as you rotate
one versus the other one,
you go from light to
dark to light to dark.
So it rotates twice in amplitude for
every single physical rotation of these
Polaroids. We did the same thing, not
with optical light but with microwaves.
And what we did is we claimed that
there was evidence for what are called
gravitational waves produced
during the big bangs,
inflationary epoch that shook up space
time so violently that it caused these
patterns to originate.
And that was what we claim we discovered.
I'm going to talk to you about that. We
use this instrument here called it bicep.
I coined the term, uh, it's uh,
stands for by background imager of
cosmic extra galactic polarization,
but it was really called that because
the pattern that we're looking for these
swirling, curling, twisting patterns.
And I thought it was kind of
cute that the Bicep, you know,
you guys go down to the gym here,
you work in the Bicep,
that's the muscle that powers
you to do curls. And I thought,
well that's kind of a cute name for this.
It's actually a gal lane spyglass.
It's just a microwave spyglass
so I brought some of our
detectors here and here
and what they look like,
but they're sensitive to wavelengths of
light of about two millimeters instead
of 500 microns. Like your ion sensitive
to, these are sensitive to much,
much longer wave lengths where the
microwave signal gets the brightest.
Where we observe these
photons from the big bang.
The lenses are made of ordinary
milk jug like material.
Let me go back just like you'd find in
a milk jug and you know that a milk jug
can actually transmit light through it
or heat through it because you've picked
up a milk jug at the supermarket and
you feel it's cold even though you can't
see through these lenses with your eye.
They transmit microwaves perfectly
and they actually bend and refract
microwave's. Instead of
landing on Galileo's a retina,
they land on these, uh,
these super conducting sensors that were
built up at JPL and they're over here
an example of those.
So these sensors transduce the microwave
heat into electrical resistance and
then we're able to measure that and the
superconductor very, very accurately.
Instead of having a, you know,
a, a 10 megapixels like the,
what's the current droid model? Uh,
so we only had about 256 pixels,
so we had less than a milli megapixel.
Uh, so it's not that powerful,
but don't take your droid and do what we
did to it. Namely cool it down to 450,
four degrees below zero Fahrenheit,
cause it won't oil void the warranty,
I'm sure about that.
And I don't know what kind of
plant replacement plan you're on.
So we ended up putting this telescope
instead of in Galileo's hands,
we put it in a mount that
we tested here in Caltech,
and then we shipped it down to
the very bottom of the world.
So this is a telescope that's very
much human sized except an addition.
Instead of looking through
visible light like Galileo did,
it looked through microwave and the
microwave regime of the electromagnetic
spectrum.
Then we digitize the resistance that
these detectors see as they scan the sky
and rotated the polarization.
Then we use supercomputers at Harvard
and elsewhere to, to process these,
you know, many, many gigabytes of
data collected over three years.
The telescope had to be brought somewhere.
Very nice.
I would have liked to have brought it,
you know, kept it at the, you know,
in San Diego or Caltech.
We ended up taking it to the South
Pole because the South Pole is the, uh,
is one of the highest and
driest continents on earth.
The Antarctica is and dryness
as important as, you know,
when you go to the commissary
here, whatever cafeteria here, um,
I don't know how you guys all stay in
shape by the way, but when you go there,
you heat up water in the microwave, the
cup, if it's ceramic will not get hot.
You can touch the cup right after boiling
the water, water absorbers, microwaves,
and it does so very efficiently.
That means water molecules in the
earth's atmosphere will also absorbed
microwaves.
We don't want that happening.
These photons have been traveling
for 13.8 2 billion years.
We don't want them to get absorbed in
a water molecule floating above our
observatory. So people say, well, why
don't you put it in space? And I said,
why don't you give me $1 billion
and I'll be happy to do that?
Because that's how much it costs a
hundred times more money to build a,
an equivalent satellite object in space
if you get permission from NASA to do
the launch or, or whoever. So,
so the early explorers in the 19 in 1911
1912 made it to the South Pole for the
first time.
No one had ever seen it.
People didn't even know
about the existence of the
continent of Antarctica until
the mid 1800 say. And, but at that point,
they only saw about half of 1% of it.
They knew nothing about this confident,
which is much, much bigger than, than
the, um, than central United States.
So this is the second team that
ever reached the South Pole.
This is a team led by Robert Falcon
Scott, and he got to the South Pole, uh,
uh, caring scientific equipment,
media rights that he had
collected along the way,
parts of Dead Sea lions that he had
found along the way. He was a scientist.
He was doing an expedition.
He refused to use dogs because all the
dogs that had ever been to Antarctica,
they're actually banned now to bring
dogs to Antarctica or any animals besides
Grad students. Just kidding. Grad
students out there, um, you're,
you're actually forbidden to bring any
animals down there because you always end
up eating them. And they would,
in fact, the, the Swedish team,
the Norwegian team that beat them,
they're led by Roald Amundsen.
Got to the South Pole
in three weeks or eight.
The dogs had a big feast at the
South Pole, put a flag in the,
in the snow and went back home down
10,000 feet of ice and 700 miles north.
Of course, everywhere is north from
there. This is the second team.
And when Scott got there, he said, great
God, this is an awful place. And you know,
I kind of felt exactly the opposite.
I felt this is a totally awesome place,
except it's not all fun and games as it
was back then for Scott. Oh no, he died.
But, but um, but we live, but
it's very dangerous place to go.
Is this video are captured last time
shows. Okay. You think it's really cute?
But no, the penguins do not try
that. Although I say, you know,
I have a lot of friends. I go out
to dinner, what they say, you know,
I can't decide between chicken
and fish. I say, have a penguin.
It's like the best nowadays. It's an
awesome place when you're down there,
the US taxpayers, you hear and
you out there and on Youtube, uh,
fund this wonderful station but $150
million station built over the last 15 or
so years, we'd get, you know,
a private room and things that
Scott could never possibly imagine.
Here's the axis on which the Earth was
spinning when I was there the last time,
uh, in 2008, 2009, the Earth is
spinning about this access and you know,
straight down through here is
the North Pole. So it's amazing.
So I can actually run around the world.
I'm not in good shape but I can
run around the world in 10 seconds.
I think it's pretty cool. There you
go. There you have to check in on,
you know Google plus.
Right? So I took a picture,
send it to Google plus and there's the
building in which we put that instrument,
that beautiful telescope that we spend
about five years building and it's called
the observatory down here.
And then I always say the observatory
is the second most important building at
the South Pole. Okay. Cause he gotta
you gotta take care of business,
but you notice the building is built up
on stilts and this might interest any of
you are on the east from the east coast
as I am originally on the east coast.
They build houses on the beach up on
stilts because they don't want sand to
cover him up or decay. The
foundation here, snow is the enemy.
Snow would eventually over overflow over
the entire building within a only about
a decade or so. So they, they
build it up on, on stilts.
The snow can blow and pass right through.
So the outhouse has been buried over
and we're working hard to get my grad
student. No, no, no. The Grad
students find a, but it is a,
they painted black to keep
it nice and warm and uh,
but it cannot be built up on
stilts that if I do, as I say,
often that would be truly worthy of a
Nobel prize. A second story. Outhouse.
Okay. Don't, don't use them until,
until I've tested them for you.
So of course, what do we have at
the South Pole? We have street view.
I love this image down here. This
is what, this is what Google thinks.
You know, if you get driving
directions to the South Hall, uh,
you get them from Google. This
is what street view shows.
So go visit street view.
You can actually pan
around and this is what,
this is what the bicep up to observatory.
It looks like. It's pretty cute.
We made a huge announcement on
Saint Patrick's Day 2014 we said,
we detected this twisting roiling boiling
surface of last scattering that was
infused.
We said with gravitational wave energy
and those gravitational waves we claimed
could only have come from inflation.
So we made this huge announcement.
It got a of attention. Uh, there was a
huge media, you know, storm about it.
There was a viral youtube video which
got millions of views. You know,
this is a scientific discovery,
but very arcane abstract topic like
inflationary universe, cosmology,
gravitational waves, microwave
astronomy. And yet within minutes,
millions of people had seen this video.
This is one of the founders of the theory
of inflation and his wife and their
professors at Stanford along with one
of my colleagues channeling quo who's a
professor at Stanford.
There was a news conference at Harvard
and there was newspaper coverage all over
the world.
The paper newspaper of record covered it.
The San Diego Union Tribune I'm
speaking about. Um, so that was here.
They put the exact number of seconds
after the big bang that we claim to make
the discovery. And I love this headline
over here. Hold on, I'll get to the onion.
And the second, I like this
headline, the economist,
cause it sounds like just
some dude was watching it.
All of a sudden he saw the beginning
of the universe wholly chow.
But for true hilarity,
we have to go to the onion.
So within days of our discovery,
the onion comes out at this headline,
top theoretical physicist and R and B
singers meet to debate the meaning of
forever. And you see down here we
can observe longterm phenomenal,
like the cosmic background radiation,
primordial B mode polarization and the
love between India, Ari and her man.
All of which seem to have existed
since the universe is infancy.
And the sub caption says,
you the participants debate
if it's theoretically
possible to give you my heart
forever. So I'll leave
it to the onion, right?
Alas are Nobel dreams were
not to last very long. Uh,
it turned out that we made a discovery
and a very consistent discovery and that
discovery turned out to be this very
mercurial substance called dust that I
began to talk with.
So it turns out that there's dust in
the interstellar medium that comes from
fail. Oops. That comes from failed stars.
Stars that have exploded
and so called Supernova.
And these dust grains can sometimes be
made of iron such as the iron in our
blood. That's exactly where it came from.
There wasn't some iron factory, you know,
that made the hemoglobin molecules,
these little grains of dust can become
magnetized if they're made of iron.
And then they become like little compass
needles and it turns out the Milky Way
Galaxy also has a magnetic field in it.
And a compass in a magnetic field will
orient towards the magnetic field lines.
And in such a case, it can actually
orient to produce the exact swirling,
twisting, curling pattern that
bicep was designed to measure.
And in fact that became the most likely
culprit for the signal that we saw.
We didn't make a blunder,
we didn't leave the lens cap on,
but what we thought we were seeing is
back to the very beginning of time,
we thought we were searching from Earth
here in the South Pole looking past all
the planets, galaxies,
plea eighties, everything.
Even back to the beginning of time,
the Big Bang, the first few, uh,
Chileans of a second after the big bang.
But instead what we were seeing was more
like dust between us and our delaxy and
the surface and an exactly acted as
an as an imposter signal mimicking the
signal. We tried to confirm, again,
this is a very pernicious phenomena,
a very common one in science confirmation
bias because we were told in part that
we would get this, uh, of this beautiful
Medallia and I'll show you in a second.
Um, uh, I do want to take away,
cause sometimes I've said,
I've given talks where people
ask me afterwards like,
you got to lay off the dust man.
Okay,
this is like you're
being too harsh on dust.
Dust is great and I want to say
that I am very appreciative of dust.
Not only does dust flow through our
star does flow through our veins,
but also as Carl Sagan poetically put it,
he turned,
he had the NASA engineers turn the
voyager satellite around after it passed
through doing the outer planets in our
solar system. And it took an image,
a selfie of the earth for millions of
miles past, past the orbit of Saturn.
And he says here, this image here, and
you can see a tiny little dot. He says,
you look at that, you see a dot. He says,
that's here. That's home. That's us.
Every saint and sinner in life.
History of our species live,
live there on a mode of
dust suspended in a sunbeam.
This is a camera artifact, the sun beam
here, but it's so poetic and it is true.
The,
the earth is a giant ball of dust that
collaborated over eons to form a solid
surface that we can stand on.
Again,
thank goodness or else we wouldn't
be here to have this conversation.
Dust creates, it creates life. It
creates planets, but it also can destroy,
I destroys Nobel prizes. And
so a, to add insult to injury,
not long after we had
the discovery retracted,
not after we went through
this embarrassing painful
process of having to retract
the claims that we made.
I note that we always have,
we always see front page
headlines and press conferences,
but you never see front page headline
retraction of previous front page headline
or a press conference. We have
to tell you we were wrong. Uh,
so it seems like the media or in part
to blame for stoking the attitude within
scientists that,
that the press conferences in newspapers,
and I'm as guilty as anyone of this,
but uh,
there's an immense pressure in
academia to, to produce these.
Everything has to be an outstanding
breakthrough and very rarely does that
actually take place.
And part of the book is written in such
a way as to give hope to people that
most people don't win the Nobel prize.
Most people don't win the Oscars.
Most people don't when they're high
school class presidency. Right?
So how do you deal with failure,
embarrassment, humiliation even,
and get back up,
dust yourself off and get back to work.
So to add insult to injury though for me,
I came into work in October of 2015 and
I found this document that said two dear
Professor Brian Keating,
we have the honor to ask you to nominate
the winners of the next Nobel prize.
Okay. So you know, it's like he got fired,
but can you give a recommendation to the
diversion that should take your job and
interview a interview her?
So this was a letter that was
mark strictly confidential.
So don't tell anybody.
Okay. Ain't nobody out there
telling anybody, but it was,
it was asking me to nominate the winners
of the Nobel Prize in physics. And, uh,
and it was a,
it was part of a small set of people
that are chosen randomly but not so
randomly as I might get a chance
to describe and Q and a but a of,
of who should win the
Nobel prize each year.
And this actually set me on a very
interesting quest that became the second
meaning of the double
entendre of the book's title.
So the first meeting is how
I lost the noble prize dude,
thanks to dust or no thanks to the US.
And the second meaning is what I learned
about the Nobel prize that shocked me.
And in the process of nominating
winters, uh, for the 2016 prize.
So I'm an academic, right? So
what do we do as academicians?
We go back and look at
primary reference material.
So I went back to Alfred Nobel's will,
and I'm fluent in Swedish as we
all are now. So I couldn't read it,
but thankfully it's translated online.
You could find it.
And what I found in his
will was really surprising.
And what it's led to in the preceding
hundred and 20 years since he wrote down
the will and hundred and set and 16 years
of Nobel prizes is quite surprising.
So what he said was in his will,
he said,
the whole of my estate should be given
and divided in the following way.
A portion of it should be given to
the person or the persons there,
the person during the preceding year who
has conferred the greatest benefit to
mankind. And it says later, one
part to the person, not in the,
in the, in the plural, in
the singular. So Nobel prize,
it should be given for discoveries or
inventions that had the greatest benefit
to mankind in the preceding year.
And I started to think, hmm,
how many astrophysics discoveries have
benefited all of mankind and done so in a
year?
And it started to make me think of like,
what were the original intents of the
Nobel prize and how did those early Nobel
Prizes get carried out? And how have we
overlooked great discoveries, uh, or not.
So I'm going to show you here.
I'm going to give a quiz, which I,
which I gave at Facebook and they all
got it right? So I want to ask you guys,
see as how you guys are. Good. Okay. So,
um, am I allowed to say Facebook? Okay.
So I wanted to ask you guys, there's
three choices here. A, B, and c.
So raise your hand if you think the
RNA molecule won the Nobel prize.
These are all eligible
for the Nobel prize.
They're all invented
after Alpha Nobel stuff.
Anybody think that the RNA molecule,
the most important precursor building
block of human life and other lives?
Nobody. Okay. A couple people. Good. The
periodic table choice B, raise your hand.
You think periodic table.
I remind you.
There's an element on there
called no Belgium. Okay.
Invented by men to live. Okay.
There's like one or two of you guys.
Good, good. And then choice c, uh,
appears to be like a lighthouse.
Anybody think the lighthouse
could the lighthouse? Really?
You guys think the light? God,
the guys at Facebook got it.
Now of course it's the lighthouse.
Of course.
It was given to Gustov the in 1912 for
his invention of automatic regulators for
using automatic automators and boom,
lighthouses and buoys.
Unbelievable. It benefits our life every
day, doesn't it? I mean I was just,
I had to come up here from San Diego
and I thank God I had those gas
accumulators guiding me
along the way. So, okay,
so maybe that was just an early blunder,
but actually it's typical.
It's actually what Alfred Nobel
wanted. He was an inventor, right?
He had Google patents Galore and he wanted
to reward things and this did benefit
back in,
you know,
people were crashing into rocks
and Sweden and he didn't want that.
So this was very typical
actually of what he wanted.
And it's more of so significantly,
you know,
to to say in 2013 when the
discovery of the Higgs Boson,
actually the prediction of the Higgs
Boson was rewarded. And I ask people like,
how often throughout the day do you say,
oh,
thank God for the Higgs Boson and like
at least the lighthouse get, you know,
did something practical.
And of course has been other controversies
with the Nobel prize. There's some, uh,
some examples,
I'm not commenting on any of them,
but just these are controversies that
have been aroused and some of the winners
have been a little bit unsavory. This
is one of the most egregious examples.
William Shockley who won the Nobel Prize
for the invention of the technology
that you guys would not have jobs without,
namely the transistor.
He got the Nobel prize and yet he said
terrible things about eugenics and ideas
for sterilization of African Americans.
And he thought that was a way
to increase the Iq of the world.
And he was one of these,
uh,
actually he was studied in this
famous study called Turmans Termites,
a study of future Nobel Prize winners,
brilliant men in society.
And they want to see is
there a correlation between
Iq and the Nobel prize.
And he was one of the counter examples
because his Iq was below average or are
about average. And, and so, and
yet he did win the Nobel prize.
There was a famous book written about
him, so he was very generous. Uh,
not with his money. Uh, putting his
money. He kept his money in the bank,
but he also kept other things in the bag.
He was one of the first donors to
the famous Nobel Prize Sperm Bank,
which is located in lovely San Diego
County. So you can come visit it. No, no,
it's not in existence anymore.
And when they went bankrupt,
I guess nobody made any
withdrawals that we know about.
But this is all done in a
social engineering eugenics
thing that you would be
put in jail to do nowadays.
So a, so that was, you know,
another controversial example.
I'll hit other ones later,
but keep in mind the criteria,
the criteria that Alfred Nobel stipulated
a single person in the preceding year
conferred the greatest benefit on mankind
for all the prizes, chemistry, physics,
physiology.
The Nobel Prize in economics was added
60 years after the first Nobel prizes.
So it wasn't part of Alfred Nobel's will
and is actually no longer called the
Nobel prize in economics. Someone
says, I won the Nobel prize in math.
You know they're lying because there's
no such thing as a Nobel prize in math.
And they also say I won the, I'm a noble
and won the Nobel Prize in economics,
actually called a much catchier name.
Now it's called the Swedish Central Bank
prize and honor the memory of Alfred
Nobel. So put that on
a tee shirt here. Yeah.
So last year the Nobel prize was given
to the discovery of gravitational waves
from the orbit of two black holes that
can crashing together about 1.3 billion
light years away from Earth.
The signals travel throughout the
universe or throughout from galaxy to our
galaxy and were detected in September of
2015 and I want to take us through this
example because what actually ended up
happening when the detection was made in
September,
2015 it was a billion years after more
than a billion years after the discovery
of the actual event.
What happened between then and and and
detection between the production of the
black hole,
a signal when these black holes crashed
and the eventual Nobel prize award is
actually illustrative of
one of the biggest problems
I have with the Nobel prize
that it can't be given away posthumously
these black holes were announced.
The detection,
these black holes were announced about
11 days after the deadline for my
nomination in 2016 so the j the January
deadline passed and you have to have
your nominations in by the 31st of January
every year or else they'll just throw
them away and they don't
save them for the next year.
The Lygo announcement was not made in
the famous press conference in DC until
the 11th of February,
so they missed that deadline.
That means I could not nominate them.
I nominated somebody else and I,
and I can invite you to guess who it was.
I,
I trust you will not be able to guess
who it is, but I don't mention who I,
who I nominated.
But I didn't get to nominate these
people because they never made the
announcement in time for
me to make the nomination.
So they would have to wait till the next
year and all was fine except for the
fact that one of the three
founding fathers of Lygo
Ronald Drever died on march
seven 2017 that meant when Lygo actually
was awarded the Nobel prize in 2017 he
was left out and another person,
Barry Barish up at Caltech took his place
and even bearer said if they had given
the prize away a year earlier,
I would not have won it because the
Nobel prize can nowadays be one by up to
three people.
Another rules change that they've made.
So what does this illustrate?
This means that if these black holes
had crashed together 11 days earlier and
everything else in the history of the
universe proceeded at the same way,
and there's no reason,
maybe they think,
not that this man would have a
Nobel prize. And in fact, uh,
and then the other men,
uh, Barry Barish would not,
so it's so capricious because of this
rule that they made up themselves in 1974.
No posthumous Nobel prizes.
And they actually have given it
away three times to three men.
And I was talking about sexism in
the price in just a second, but, uh,
they give it away. The three men and two
of the three were Swedish men. Okay. So,
uh,
so some people say there's,
there's lots of forms of bias with
the Nobel prize. So, uh, uh, you know,
sort of poor Ron drivers memory and
his family don't have this accolade to
really look back on. Now this is going
to become a big problem. This, this,
this plat hair.
I've been told you guys are very
quantitative and you eat up data. Um,
like I'm going to eat up
lunch in a little bit. Uh,
this shows the long timescales between
the discovery of a Nobel worthy invention
or discovery and the award for
several different branches of science,
fixating on physics.
These blue curves here,
it shows that from the 19 hundreds up
to 2000 it's now getting up to about 30
years plus between discovery of an effect
and the Nobel prize that's awarded for
that discovery and what's not increasing.
And then I made a plot in my book where
I took data from the Nobel Prize website
on the age of different people when
they won the Nobel prize in each decade.
And I came up with this plot here.
I say this plot here and it
shows that the early Nobel prize,
the average age was in the,
you know,
say 50s then it went down to 40 almost
and now it's been rising faster than a of
years per decade. And a
couch are eventually going
to hit this deadline, right?
Think so. There's not,
there's not too much.
I mean maybe you guys can help with this,
but eventually the average age of the
Nobel laureates this past year was 78
years old. The three men average age 78
so this is going to become very serious.
Where the passion is. Price is always
going to be given away. Unless you guys,
and this could actually happen,
I predict in a few years,
it could be that artificial
intelligence wins Nobel prizes. Why not?
There's nothing. It says, it says the
person, well, they already gave up the,
and so why can't they
give a person as well?
So I want to just point out a couple of
technicalities and this is who gets to
nominate the winners of the Nobel prize.
You don't need to read,
it's mostly Swedish Nordic,
Nordic people.
And then down here there's people like me,
people that the academy
sees fit to ask to nominate.
So that was my category number
six in the pecking order.
But notice number three in the pecking
order are Nobel laureates in physics.
So if you win a Nobel prize,
you're automatically entitled for the
rest of your life to nominate winners of
the Nobel Prize.
And that has important ramifications.
It turns out you're five times more
likely to win a Nobel prize if your phd
advisor was a Nobel laureate or your
postdoctoral advisor was a Nobel laureate.
And that's part of this,
this, this phenomenon.
So a and that means it's harder to
break into that. Like if you're,
if you're from a different group than
is traditionally been awarded the Nobel
prize to break into that,
whether women or minorities,
it becomes harder and harder for them to
also get into this track where they can,
the rich can get richer so to speak.
And they gave me the last piece
of helpful advice they gave me.
No one can nominate him or herself.
So that was helpful and not
narrowed it down by one person. Um,
so I wasn't allowed to do that.
I want to talk briefly about this clause.
This is actually the opening statement
of the Nobel Prize. Endowing will says,
I Alfred Nobel do here by
after mature deliberation,
declared my falling to my last will
and testament to my nephew [inaudible].
I don't know how to pronounce that.
And Ludvig I bequeath the sum of 200,000
Swedish crowns to my niece, Mina.
I give 100,000 crowns so the men
got twice as much as the wind.
Some people joke that this is the
root of the Nobel prizes sexism.
I think it actually runs deeper than that.
Nobody knows why he gave the women
the woman half as much as the men,
but speaking of, you know,
half as much or two entities.
These are all the women who have won the
Nobel Prize in physics. The first one,
Marie Curie won it in early 19 hundreds
and she was almost denied it. In fact,
they weren't going to give it to her
until her husband and Colorino and said,
I'm not going to accept my prize for
radio activity unless you give it also to
my wife, because she did most of the
work. So they ended up giving it to her,
but it was grudgingly.
And then Maria get bird Mayer who
is at Uc San Diego where I am,
she won the last Nobel Prize in physics
in 1963 54 years ago was the last woman
to win the Nobel Prize and, and
physics. And when she wanted,
she was only able to win it
after being nominated 27 times,
which is twice as many times as Albert
Einstein had to be nominated to win it.
Why is that such a big,
Albert Einstein was forbidden almost
by the rules of the regulations of the
early part of the 19 hundreds because
Jews weren't allowed to win it.
And in fact, because previous winners
were allowed to nominate future winners,
and they were the part of the committee
that decided who wins the Nobel prize,
they were including Hitler's chief of
Arion physics and man by the name of
Phillip Lin art, who had won
the 19, uh, 1905 Nobel prize.
He had a mandate that Einstein could
not win the Nobel Prize because he
practiced theoretical physics,
which was a form of world
bluffing Jewish physics.
So Einstein was forbidden, but only for
15 years. Women have not won it in 50,
you know,
first it was they didn't win it and then
she had to be nominated 27 times before
she actually wanted.
So it's just remarkable.
And when she wanted in our
hometown paper in San Diego,
the paper of record throughout the world,
the San Diego Union Tribune,
the headline read San Diego,
housewife wins Nobel prize.
That was the headline in October,
1963 just incredible.
Here's a graph shows women a
fraction of women, you know,
so there's only been two women that
want it. So I always joke, you know,
that means that there's only two more
female Nobel Prize winners in physics than
there have been female pope's. Okay.
Female Pope's people. Okay. All right.
Um, so again, why could this be, well,
one reason is this clause that previous
Nobel laureates can nominate future
Nobel laureates and that could be
part of the reason that we have this.
Of course I like to point out,
I don't know,
I've been giving this talk a couple of
times to other other groups of people and
I, and I keep showing this,
maybe you guys will get it,
but the back of the Nobel prize medallion,
if I turned my real Nobel prize
over here, no, if I fake one,
you'll find two women,
Mother Nature and this God has known as
the genius of science and she's taking
the veil off mother nature's
face. So that's pretty cool. Um,
but I noticed that like what we really
have is that you have a picture depicting
two women and they're kind of,
you know,
wouldn't be having this conversation
unless there was a dude there.
And so this is an example of a failure
of what's called the Bechdel test.
If you guys know about that,
that's a very important scientific test.
But it has actually
another example of that.
So I wrote this book and part of the
book I joke is about idol worship. Uh,
so in,
in physics there is no greater stature
then you can have than to be a Nobel
laureate. It's really something
that people aspire to. So much so.
And I have no problems with
the people who have won it. A,
it's more of the committee
and the structure and the
system that I believe has
systemic problems that
are preventing, um, uh,
the meritocratic award of prizes. And
maybe during Q and a, I can address those.
This is a, uh, uh, a friend of
a former colleague at UC SD.
This is professor Dunkin Haldane.
He ended up winning the 2016 Nobel Prize.
The one that I was nominating a
winners of. I did not nominate him.
Do not tell him. Okay. I did
not nominate him, but he won.
He actually won with one of my former
professors at Brown University,
Michael Costa, let's, and
another gentleman and he
came back to UC SD that day.
I submitted the first draft of this book,
losing the Nobel Prize. In this book,
I decry how physicists elevate the Nobel,
the status of idols that they
basically are willing to, to, you know,
kind of sacrifice so much
and really to be an awe and,
and bask in the aura of the
laureates. And the Nobel prize. Look,
I took this picture you can't hardly see.
Then it glows with a white hot
intensity and it just has a super,
super luminant glow to it.
And look how all these students,
and then the faculty that came up to
him and they were oohing and aahing and
just gushing over him. It was pathetic. I
was like, you guys are rational science.
He supposed to be the most rational,
you know,
critical thinkers in all of humanity. How
could you stoop solar? It's disgusting.
Oh my God. Somehow the Nobel
prize gets in my hand selfie.
Okay. Even I would have been given
this incredible, you know, uh,
opportunity to a sale,
the Nobel prize from the insides and
dissected and appoint out all of its flaws
too to make it better. Uh, succumb to it.
And he's luckily a very wonderful man.
I want to close a talk with a couple
of points as to what will come next,
both in cosmology and in the Nobel prize,
hopefully.
So getting back to my theme, dust
to dust, we began or talk with dust.
Dust came in as a villain,
but I want to point out a very noble,
a person about an Ama,
Mahatma Gandhi.
And he gave some advice to
experimentalists like me
in this story called the
story of my experiments with truth.
Gandhi said the seeker after truth
should be humbler than the dust.
The world crushes dust under its feet.
But the secret after truth should so
humble himself that even the dust could
crush him only then and not until
then will he have a glimpse of truth.
And I think that's part of what we need
to have as cosmologist and as practicing
scientist in general,
to look for ways to be humble and have
humility in order to strive and make the,
that make the great leads without
focusing on arbitrary awards or accolades,
prizes, money, whatever you venerate
to the level of, of your idol.
So what comes next in science
is a huge collaboration.
BICEP had 49 people all, you know,
all of which would not have written,
most of which would not have won the
Nobel prize even if we were confirmed. Uh,
instead we have a much
bigger collaboration building
on the lessons of Bicep,
I suppose,
not a failure.
It was one of the most successful
experiments in history because it measured
signals that are so minute
that no experiment has
caught up to what we did with
bicep even after four years after the uh,
announcement.
So we didn't retract them findings,
we retracted while we claimed
as the interpretation,
we said we saw the
fingerprints of creation,
we really saw the dusty fingerprints
of the Milky Way Galaxy.
So now we're taking lessons learned.
We're building this big observatory in
the Atacama desert of Chile called the
Simons Observatory.
And this telescope is going to be located,
here's a street view or Google
earth view for you guys out there.
And it shows kind of the killer app
for this technology is a new type of
detector, same kind of
superconducting instrumentation,
except that uses a
fractal pattern in tena.
And this fractal antenna has extremely
wide bandwidth frequency coverage.
So can simultaneously measure dust and
measure the cosmic signals if they're
truly, and then from the some of the
cosmic signal and the dust signal,
we're going to subtract the dust signal
and what will be left with hopefully as
the pristine signal from
the early universe. But we
won't know until we do it.
What's the other part of,
you know,
call to action next and the
Nobel kind of front? Well,
I want to close with the final
sentence and Alfred Nobel's will,
he said is my final request that after
my death my veins shall be opened.
And when this has been done and competent
doctors have confirmed clear signs of
death, my remains to be cremated and our
crematorium, why did he want to do this?
Well, he was terribly afraid
of being buried alive.
It was a condition that
people were, that's called
tap a phobia. I googled that.
And, and it means that you're
terrified of being buried alive.
So much so that in caskets they used
to put bells so that if you were buried
alive, you had this, you know,
intercom system and you could,
you could ring the bell and people would
open you up. But I like to point out,
you know, if he wasn't dead and
then the doctors opened his veins,
that would be kind of the, the
coup de Gras, right? So he,
he cure his tap a phobia right there.
But it made me think we should not be
scared of opening the veins on the prize
and really examining the depths
of what the prize is become.
So in the news just this week,
these are all headlines from this week.
Nobel prize is all over the headlines.
It's great publicity for my book. But um,
but there's a sex scandal rocking
the Nobel prize in literature.
There's a financial crimes unit,
which is investigating the Nobel,
the Nobel Committee's Donald Trump is in
the news for a potentially being worthy
of the Nobel prize for peace and a,
and then there's people that are defecting
from the Nobel committee because they
don't want to have a part of it anymore.
So it's a very dangerous time.
And I claim that,
that the committee wants to save these
prizes to restore them to the luster,
the lure that they once had and
the, you know, so if you do, um,
if you do one of your Google searches on,
on the search terms and their popularity
over history, what's that called again?
You guys shoot on Google trends.
So I did a Google trends and I looked
up a Pulitzer prize versus Nobel prize.
It turned out for the early
part of the 19 hundreds,
the Pulitzer prize is much more
popular than the Nobel prize. In fact,
the first noble prizes, the winters
didn't even show up to get them.
Nowadays 100 million people watch
them on youtube and in person.
So they've gone just
exponentially more popular.
They're moving into this glitzy
new building in Stockholm.
It's billions of dollars at
stake and the national prestige.
So if they want to save it, I've
made some proposals in this book, uh,
that I think are very concrete,
very well organized.
I color coded the pages in the book.
There's three chapters about the Nobel
prize. So if you don't care about it,
you can skip those three colors in the
kind of choose your own adventure book
like we used to use as kids.
But I want to use the prestige and the
name of the prize to reform it for the
better.
So we've established a site which we
call when you call losing the Nobel
prize.org and it has the capacity to
submit petitions to the Nobel Committee's
to advocate for both
rectification of past prizes.
Say this is Jocelyn Bell who discovered
pulsars radio beacon. So bright.
You can set your watch to them
and see them across the galaxy.
Her advisor got the Nobel prize, but she
didn't. It's called the Matilda effect.
When a man gets a credit for
the discovery of a woman,
there's nothing in the Nobel statutes
that prevents her from winning the Nobel
prize.
Just because her advisor wanted it
would seem that if you want a justice to
prevail,
she shouldn't be allowed to win it.
Or what about Ron Drever who died and
didn't win it or beer or Ruben who died
just on Christmas Day 2016. Why shouldn't
she when it, when physicists say, well,
you couldn't, you can't win it
once you're dead. I say, Oh,
I forgot what law of physics.
He talks about that for the Nobel prize
and it doesn't and we shouldn't treat it
like a law of physics.
So I urge people,
if you're interested after reading
the book, um, go to the site,
losing the Nobel prize.org.
You can submit petitions and I thank you
so much for your attention and I hope
that you'll visit us on online as well.
Thank you.
Thank you so much Brian. That
was amazing. Um, it's, uh,
we're a little bit after time,
but if anyone wants to ask a question,
we have the ability to do that.
So just raise your hand.
I can throw something at you.
Uh,
so it seems like the early universe has
a lot of quantum chaotic effects in it.
Do you ever see that it's perceivable
to simulate potentially with a quantum
computer or the evolution of the universe?
Yeah. So yeah. So is it possible to
simulate? So it turns out in physics,
most of my colleagues,
um, and friends who,
including a professor John Presto up at
Caltech here and people in San Diego, um,
they tell me that a lot of the, the,
the power of a quantum computer,
at least in her,
in terms of solving practical problems,
are toward solving quantum systems.
So solving Lagrand Jan's or things
that are really complicated,
quantum mechanical, um, uh,
variables and plotting wave
functions and things like that.
So if indeed the universe is described
by a wave function or what's called
[inaudible] that describes how the
energy and transfer of energy took place,
then yes,
quantum computers could have a
revolutionary capability to understand it.
I should say though,
that there's a divisiveness
in the cosmology community
right now and it's every
bit as combatitive as the old debate
between the steady state universe and the
Big Bang theory. So, you know,
we don't have a TV show called
the steady state theory, right?
So we have the Big Bang theory
that would be pretty boring. Uh,
but the steady state there,
she used to hate the Big Bang
theory is for a variety of reasons,
but one of which was that you
couldn't falsify the big bang.
You could keep changing the models of the
proud owners of the theory in order to
get what you want.
It nowadays are echoes of that debate
and what's called the multiverse,
which is a consequence of inflation
and in many models of the inflationary
universe.
And there's a new type of a variant of
the steady state called sick lick or
bouncing cosmologies where our
universe didn't have a quantum state.
It actually just collapsed from a
previous universe. Expanded again,
what we call that expansion
point is the big bang,
but there's no quantum transition.
So in those universes there's only
classical physics at work and in that case
our classical computers are
sufficient to deal with that physics.
But nobody's simulated that.
Right.
I think people are now,
there are people that are doing it.
They're also simulating a, I I've seen
on classical computer simulations of um,
you know, it's called quantum
chromo dynamic effects,
the vacuum and actually understanding
how particles can pop out virtually and
the vacuum. And I think it's just a
matter of time before the first step,
in my opinion, will probably be, I mean,
somebody out there might
already be doing this,
but first use quantum computers on the
QCD Lagrand Geans and then transferred to
the vacuum state of the inflationary at
park. I think it's eminently possible.
I hadn't thought of that.
It's a really good point.
Yeah.
Couple of questions.
So you talked about the pressure to
get scientific results out there,
to have these major impact,
uh, press conferences.
And it seems that that
was part of the issue.
Have you given a thought to
reforming that process as well?
Yeah, so I've, I've thought
a lot about that. And, um,
I was gratified to see that,
you know,
and my colleagues that are in the medical
school or law schools or whatever,
they have to take classes in ethics
and that's part of the curriculum. And,
and even, um, and even people
that are, you know, in,
in university settings and other cases
that may, we'll study ethic ethics, but a,
in physics and cosmology,
I never have class in ethics.
They barely teach us how
to be a professor. So, um,
so what I would like to see is the
ethical implications of making it an
announcement like this. It could have
potentially impacted very young people,
graduate students and post docs, and
then the, the notion of the retraction.
And then oftentimes you hear something
called like the Keating effect and then
it's debunked. And then there'll be, you
know, Keating's ground students, you know,
so you'll get the name transfer
and they'll be the, the,
the Grad student blunder.
Okay. Um, my Grad students never make
blunders. Uh, but, but nevertheless,
a lot of times the power hierarchy must
be preserved. And I think the, the, the,
the perception of science as being
purely meritocratic error correcting,
I think it,
I think it's a little bit bogus.
I think that scientists are a
little bit too, too full of,
of how they view themselves as, you know,
it's kind of like, well, ethics are easy.
You know, we're really smart. We have high
qs, you know, we give this burn back. No,
we don't do that, but, but, um, but, you
know, we can, we can intuit these laws,
but I don't think so. I think, you
know, so we're actually having a, uh,
a play done in San Diego, uh, by the,
uh, by the, the Department of, of,
of theaters putting on a play
about an ethical dilemma faced by,
and I had nothing to do with this by a
physicist who's on the verge of winning a
Nobel prize.
I always point out,
I think it'd be a really cool play or
book and maybe there'll be my next book.
Um, you know, there's four Nobel
worthy discoverers of some, you know,
cure for cancer or whatever.
And then you know,
it's a murder mystery because
only three can win it. Right?
So how do you deal with these issues
of credit of priority in science?
It's citations. You guys know
this, this Google scholar,
it's one of the tools we use
every single day. And you know,
how do you determine who got there first?
It's who wrote the first paper and
who made the first announcement.
And a lot of journals like nature
and science won't allow you to,
to do a press conference until you've
had peer review. We bypass that and we,
we open sourced it thinking that high
time that we get away from the Stodgy old
journal system that's
been around for 200 years.
It probably would have been better
if we had brought in at least,
if not an ethical kind of consultants,
but even bringing in your competitors
because they're not going to scoop you.
And all in a day or two
before the results, sit down,
talk about them that it air your dirty
laundry and do so in the scheme of what
we ended up doing,
which is to understand the universe,
we actually ended up working with
our arch nemesis at the time,
which is this Planck satellite.
Yeah.
Okay. So my question is related to
that question. Okay. So I want to know,
what do you think about the true
impact of Nobel Prize and science?
Like would there be less or
more scientific advancement
if there was no Nobel
prize? Yeah, it's interesting.
So I've been getting two different
types of comments. One is that Oh,
you have sour grapes,
you're a sore loser.
And I point out where like a lot of the
book is written about women in science
and minorities in science
and you know, I'm not a woman
in science, right? So, and,
and kind of advocating for past
injustices to be rectified. Um,
and then a lot of other things are saying,
well no, the number Keating's right.
Cause the Nobel prize is
so superlative that people,
even than last year's Nobel Prize
winner, he called the Nobel Prize, uh,
the original sin in physics.
In other words,
it was the thing that was responsible for
making so many premature announcements
about discoveries of
gravitational waves earlier,
even earlier than our discovery
in the 70s. And so, um,
and then there are people that say,
you know, they really do venerate.
I mean we're taught, I was talking
with, with Keith, I think about it,
we're taught the history of
physics really. We don't know it.
And when I teach my undergraduates,
I'm, I'm, I'm teaching them here,
all these Nobel worthy, you know,
things that we discovered, you know,
that's not my intention. I just say, well,
here's the Michelson Morley a factor.
Here's the, you know, Fineman
path or girl effect. And,
and I go through it and then you look
back and say, all those are Nobel prize.
But that's not the way science goes.
Science proceeds forward in history,
looking back in history. Okay, that was a
wrong turn that they could have avoided.
So I think there is this excess elephant
emphasis placed on the Nobel prize.
I think many scientists much more,
you know,
a kind of even killed them than myself.
They're able to,
to not even care about it. And that's
kind of the place that I'm at now.
People say, well you wouldn't, you know,
you, you and turn it down and I say,
well try me. You want to see
if I'm sincere offered me
the Nobel prize next year.
But in reality,
I think it influences some people.
Just like I always say the Academy Awards,
I don't think you guys are
here in Hollywood area, right?
So I don't think any
actor or actress says,
my whole goal in life is to win an Oscar.
Cause you know,
you're going to be one of
150 million women that could
win the ask her each year.
But the, you better believe that the
movie studios wants you to win an Oscar.
And they want every single,
you know, except for, you know,
whatever weekend at Bernie's nine.
But, but you know, they invest in it.
And B and g, who are the analogs
of the movie studios in science,
the National Science Foundation, NASA, the
Department of Energy, the not, you know,
so all these three letter
agencies for later, they all want,
and if you go to their websites and
Google on their websites to see,
you'll find it instantaneously. Here are
all the Nobel laureates and including,
you know, places like laboratories and
private industries. So it's a very big,
it's a subtle pressure
and definitely receive it.
I think that's all we have. Time
for it. Thank you very much.
Thank you guys for coming.
[inaudible].